هذا واعلن الكريم ان اهداف روسيا في
اوكرانيا لا يمكن تحقيقها في الوقت الحالي
الا بالسبل العسكريه وقال المتحدث باسم
الكريم
ان تحقيق الاهداف الروسيه يظل اولويه
مطلقه مشيرا الى ان تحقيقها ممكن الان لكن
بالسبل العسكريه فقط واكد ان الكريملم لا
يرى في الوقت الراغي اي اشارات لانتقال
الوضع بشان اوكرانيا الى طريق سلميه
متابعه لاخر التطورات الميدانيه معنا من
موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي مراسل
الجزيره حسن الشوبكي ابدى معك راني وما
ذكرته في نشره سابقه عن التحذير الروسي ان
ما قد يقع
فيما يتعلق بالجمله الاوكرانيين قد يكونوا
تكرار لسيناريو ما حدث في ماريوبول
[تصفيق]
نعم بالفعل عبد القادر الاوضاع في حاليا
هي يعني صعبه للغايه الجانب الروسي يؤكد
ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تتكبد خسائر
كبيره وتعيش في ظل اوضاع صعبه في ظل
التقدم المستمر للقوات المسلحه الروسيه في
مختلف المحاور في باخموت القوات الروسيه
تقترب لمركز المدينه هذا ما اكد عليه امس
مالك شركه فارغنراني الذي اشار لانه على
الرغم من ان يعني القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه تتشبث بكل متر مربع من الاراضي
في قلب المدينه الا ان الاوضاع تتجه نحو
تحقيق النصر قريبا
على الرغم من صعوبه المعارك والمعارك
ضاريه في مختلف المحاور فضلا عن ذلك وفقا
لي المعطيات العسكريه
القوات الروسيه تتقدم حتى من الشمال
الغربي ومن الغرب في الشمال الغربي تمكنت
بحسب هذه المصادر من
يعني من احداث فجوه في خطوط الدفاعات في
خطوط الدفاعات القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وباتت تسيطر على الجزء الاكبر من منطقه
اليخفا وسيلوفكا فضلا عن ذلك
تمكنت من اختراق اخر معاقل الدفاعيه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه غربي المدينه
وهنا اود الاشاره الى ما تم الافصاح عنه
من قبل الخبراء والمراقبين الذين اشاروا
الى ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في حال
لم تتلقى الامر قريبا بترك المدينه
ومغادرتها يعني فانها فان ذلك يعني فانها
لن تستطيع مغادرتها في القريب العاجل عبر
خط الطريق السريع تشاه سفيان مشير للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه السلاح الجوي بات يستخدم
قنابل موجهه تايزن وطنا ونصف الطن وان
يعني المقاومه الاوكرانيه في ظل استخدام
هذه القنابل يعني يمكن القول في شبه
معدومه وعليه فانه في حال دق هذا الامر
فانها ستواجه مدينه
نفس مصير مدينه مريوفل يعني الذي تم اتمام
السيطره عليها قبل نحو سبعه اشهر من الان
وعليه فان الاوضاع في غايه الصعوبه وحتى
يعني طريق الذي لا تزال القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه عبد القادر تستطيع الخروج منه
على الرغم من القصف المستمر لهذا الطريق
من قبل القوات المسلحه
الروسيه ولكن الاوضاع فعلا صعبه امس كانت
هناك قافله للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
يعني مدعومه بالاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
تم تدميرها من قبل القوات المسلحه الروسيه
وعليه فان الاوضاع بالفعل صعبه يعني
والقوات الاوكرانيه يعني يعني تعيش في ظل
اوضاع هذا ما اكد عليه ايضا مالك شركه
فاجن الجانب الرو